For three weeks, Joe Biden said as forcefully as a human being possibly could say that he would not step down. And for three weeks, it was this agonizing drip, drip, drip of people trying to get him to reconsider and of voters around the country wondering if he was going to reconsider.
在过去三周里，乔·拜登以人类所能表达的最强硬的态度声称他不会退选。而在那三周里，这是一个令人痛苦的缓慢过程：人们不断尝试让他重新考虑，全国各地的选民也在猜测他是否会回心转意。
Fed by a steady stream of daily news stories that read tea leaves and applied electron microscopes to the tiniest scraps of evidence, looking for any minuscule signs indicating that maybe it could happen, maybe Biden would rethink things. Democrats wondering what it might take to change Biden's mind.
每天不断的各种新闻报道，都在仔细揣摩其言外之意，甚至用“电子显微镜”去审视最微小的证据，试图寻找任何一点点他可能改变主意的迹象。民主党人则在猜测，到底需要什么才能改变拜登的想法。
Meanwhile, over in the other half of the country, in red-state America, at the Republican National Convention, people who had changed their minds and reconsidered firmly held convictions were a big part of the festivities. Donald Trump picked his vice president, a man who once said about him, "My god, what an idiot," JD Vance. Nikki Haley, who had once called Trump unhinged, and other former Trump rivals, people who once seemed like they hated Trump and spoken out against him, took the stage to show how they'd reconsidered.
与此同时，在国家另一半的“红州”美国，共和党全国代表大会上，那些已经改变想法、重塑坚定信念的人成了庆典的重要组成部分。唐纳德·特朗普选择了他的副总统人选——万斯（JD Vance），一个曾经称他为“天哪，真是个白痴”的人。曾经称特朗普为“精神错乱”的尼基·黑利（Nikki Haley）以及其他曾经的对手，那些看似憎恨特朗普并公开发表反对言论的人，纷纷登台展示他们是如何改变看法的。
And even Trump himself, the centerpiece of the whole thing, seemed to be presenting himself as a changed man, somebody who had reconsidered who he wants to be in the wake of his near assassination. He presented a notably gentler, uniter-not-divider side of himself. All this reconsideration, of course, was in the service of getting the swing voters of the swing states to do some reconsideration of their own about who they might be picking for president this fall.
甚至特朗普本人，作为整个事件的核心，似乎也表现得像个改过自新的人，一个在险些遭遇暗杀后重新思考自己想要成为什么样的人。他表现出了明显更温和、团结者而非分裂者的一面。当然，所有这些“重新考虑”都是为了让摇摆州的摇摆选民对今年秋天该选谁当总统进行他们自己的重新考虑。
I sometimes feel like the rarest thing in the world is to witness somebody actually changing their mind. You know what I mean? Changing their mind about something big, some fundamental belief. I mean, I know it happens, right? Most of us know people who are never going to have kids who decide they're going to go for it, or Democrats who became Republicans, pro-lifers who switched to pro-choicers.
我有时觉得世界上最罕见的事情就是见证一个人真正改变自己的想法。你知道我的意思吗？改变对某件大事、某种基本信仰的看法。我是说，我知道这确实会发生，对吧？我们大多数人都认识那些原本不想要孩子却决定尝试的人，或者从民主党转为共和党的人，从反堕胎主义者转变为支持堕胎权利的人。
When it happens, it's a seismic thing. And that point of transition, when you're flipping from one way of seeing things to the new way, that is a weird, awkward thing to live through.
当这种情况发生时，它是一场地震。而那个过渡点，当你从一种看待事物的方式翻转到新方式的时候，那是一种极其尴尬、奇特的经历。
And so today on our show, in this moment when Joe Biden seems to have reconsidered some of his most deeply held ideas about himself and his chances in this election, we have stories of people rethinking some big, basic beliefs that they've taken for granted, trying on a new attitude toward the world. And we watch how that goes for them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以今天在我们的节目中，在这个乔·拜登似乎已经重新考虑了他对自己及竞选胜算的一些最根深蒂固的想法的时刻，我们讲述了一些人重新思考他们理所当然的一些重大基本信念，尝试以新态度对待世界的故事。我们来看看他们的情况如何。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act one, Fate of the Union. Of all the people who'd rethought their feelings about Donald Trump at the Republican National Convention in Milwaukee this week, there was one guest for whom the rethink has been especially dramatic, and that's Sean O'Brien. A lifelong Democrat from Massachusetts, Sean O'Brien is the head of the Teamsters Union. 1.3 million truck drivers, rail, air, all transportation, delivery workers, lots of jobs, they endorsed Biden in 2020.
第一幕，联邦的命运。在本周密尔沃基共和党全国代表大会上，所有重新考虑对唐纳德·特朗普看法的人中，有一位嘉宾的转变尤为戏剧性，那就是肖恩·奥布莱恩（Sean O'Brien）。作为一名来自马萨诸塞州的终身民主党人，肖恩·奥布莱恩是卡车司机工会（Teamsters Union）的负责人。该工会有130万名卡车司机、铁路、航空、所有运输及配送工人，他们曾在2020年支持拜登。
And Sean O'Brien was at the RNC to give a speech-- a big speech, actually, the keynote speech on the first night of the convention. I should say, the Teamsters Union president hasn't spoken at the RNC ever before in the entire history of the union, because-- maybe this is obvious-- Republicans have been the party of big business and generally pretty opposed to organized labor. Zoe Chace tells how this played out.
肖恩·奥布莱恩在共和党全国代表大会上发表了演讲，实际上是第一晚的基调演讲。我得说，卡车司机工会主席在大会历史上从未在共和党全代会上发过言，因为——或许这显而易见——共和党一直是代表大企业的政党，通常非常反对有组织工会。佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）讲述了这一切是如何发生的。
Here's how weird it is that this guy, Sean O'Brien, is at the RNC in the first place. President Biden, a Democrat, calls himself the most pro-union president in history. There's reasons. He bailed out union pensions. The Teamsters were pushing for that. All his major infrastructure bills have included money and benefits specifically for unions. He walked a picket line with the United Auto Workers. He gave his first 2020 campaign speech from a Teamsters Hall.
这个叫肖恩·奥布莱恩的家伙出现在共和党全代会本身就非常诡异。拜登总统，一位民主党人，自称是有史以来最支持工会的总统。这是有原因的：他救助了工会的养老金，卡车司机工会曾为此推动；他所有的重大基础设施法案都包含了专门针对工会的资金和福利；他与全美汽车工人联合会一起参加了罢工；他在2020年的第一次竞选演讲也是在卡车司机大厅发表的。
Donald Trump has a record, too, as a Republican president, of rolling back regulations that protected unions, appointing Supreme Court justices who ruled against unions, and of course, hiring non-union workers when he was a real estate developer, notoriously stiffing his workers out of overtime. Both of them talk about loving American workers, obviously. That's politics. But their policies are very different.
唐纳德·特朗普作为共和党总统也有过往记录：取消保护工会的法规，任命反对工会的最高法院法官，当然，还有他在担任房地产开发商时雇用非工会工人，且因臭名昭著地克扣工人的加班费而闻名。显然，他们两人都声称热爱美国工人，这就是政治。但他们的政策截然不同。
So when Teamsters President Sean O'Brien showed up at the Republican Convention this week, he felt like an outsider right away. Or maybe he wanted to make the point that he was an outsider right away.
所以，当卡车司机工会主席肖恩·奥布莱恩本周出现在共和党大会上时，他立刻感觉自己像个局外人。或者，也许他就是想强调自己是个局外人。
So I'm backstage. And the rehearsal the night before, we came in, and they just wanted to show us the setup of the stage. So--
所以我正在后台。前一天晚上的排练我们进场时，他们只是想向我们展示舞台的布局。所以——
They're telling Sean how to walk across the stage to the podium. He's going to be the keynote speaker on night one.
他们正在告诉肖恩如何穿过舞台走到讲台。他将是第一晚的基调演讲者。
And so they said, no, you got to do a dogleg right when you come out of the stage and come down. But the gentleman said, you know golf? You know how you do a dogleg right? I said, look, in my business, if you're a good golfer, you're a bad representative. I don't golf. So he says, just make, like, a little arc.
他们说，你从舞台出来时必须先走个右狗腿弯（dogleg right）。但我问那位先生，你懂高尔夫吗？你知道什么是右狗腿弯吗？我说，听着，在我的行业里，如果你是个好的高尔夫球手，那你就是个糟糕的代表。我不打高尔夫。于是他说，那就画个小弧线。
He's like, it was a bad example. OK.
他说这是一个坏例子。好吧。
So here I am, hopefully delivering the most powerful speech for American workers. And I'm debating what a dogleg is with the person. So it actually-- it was typical to my nature. I get distracted and start talking to him about how union officials shouldn't golf because they should be out working.
所以，我希望能为美国工人发表最有力的演讲。而我却在跟那个人争论什么是狗腿弯。这实际上很符合我的天性。我会分心，然后开始跟他谈论工会官员不应该打高尔夫球，因为他们应该出去工作。
Sean O'Brien seems to be here to walk a fine line, basically, with Republicans. He's like, look, this is a major prime-time slot where you don't expect to hear from us, where we get to talk to people who aren't usually listening. He describes his mission as enlightening the Republican National Convention on how important workers and unions are to this country, and maybe make some new political allies.
肖恩·奥布莱恩似乎是为了在共和党人之间走钢丝。他说，看，这是一个黄金时段，你们通常不会听到我们的声音，在这里我们可以接触到平时不听我们说话的人。他描述自己的使命是向共和党大会阐明工人和工会对这个国家的重要性，并可能建立一些新的政治盟友。
He's been on this charm offensive with Republicans for months. He went to Mar-a-Lago. He met with Trump, took a thumbs-up picture with him. He's been meeting with Republican senators, including hard-line conservative Josh Hawley, who ended up walking union picket lines.
几个月来，他一直对共和党人进行这种“魅力攻势”。他去了海湖庄园，会见了特朗普，并与他合影竖起大拇指。他还一直在会见共和党参议员，包括强硬派保守党人乔什·霍利（Josh Hawley），后者最终也加入了工会的罢工纠察线。
O'Brien told me, we have a really diverse union in all the ways, including politically. A big chunk of his membership supports Trump, and he's here partly for them. But some of organized labor is not happy with him at all. It's hard to overstate. Appalled, enraged, apoplectic, horrified. A vice president of the Teamsters Union publicly called it unconscionable.
奥布莱恩告诉我，我们的工会在各方面都非常多元化，包括政治上。他很大一部分会员支持特朗普，他来这里部分也是为了他们。但一些有组织工会的人对他非常不满。这很难被夸大。感到震惊、愤怒、暴跳如雷、恐怖。卡车司机工会的一位副主席公开称这“不可理喻”。
So as I think of O'Brien going to the RNC and doing his song and dance, I got to go, what's the message? What's he going to say?
所以当我想到奥布莱恩去共和党全代会唱歌跳舞时，我不得不问，信息是什么？他打算说什么？
This is Rick Smith's radio show. He's a 35-year Teamster, a truck driver. He thinks O'Brien's just going to be part of the Trump campaign's long-running political theater of being a party for blue-collar workers without making any actual policy that helps those workers. To him, it's like, what's O'Brien going to get for this?
这是里克·史密斯（Rick Smith）的广播节目。他是一名有35年工龄的卡车司机。他认为奥布莱恩只是在参与特朗普竞选团队长期以来的政治表演，即假装自己是一个为蓝领工人服务的政党，却没有任何实际政策能真正帮助那些工人。对他来说，他在想：奥布莱恩能从中得到什么？
The reality is is Sean O'Brien is going to be their whipping boy. They are going to use him and my Teamsters Union as their hood ornament as they drive their anti-union policy truck right over the top of working people. And the reality is is Sean O'Brien is going to be their dancing show pony, whether he wants to be or not.
现实情况是，肖恩·奥布莱恩将成为他们的“替罪羊”。他们会利用他以及我的卡车司机工会作为“汽车引擎盖上的装饰品”，同时用他们的反工会政策之车碾压工人阶级。现实情况是，无论肖恩·奥布莱恩是否愿意，他都将成为他们表演的“舞动小马”。
And they're going to ride him until election day, because what they understand, what Trump understands, what the RNC gets by giving him this platform, is a lot of his members vote for Republicans. This is making it OK. This is going, yeah, don't worry about your job. Don't worry about any of that stuff. It's OK. It's fine.
他们会利用他直到选举日。因为他们明白，特朗普明白，共和党全代会给予他这个平台是因为很多他的会员投票给共和党。这让一切变得名正言顺。这就像在说：没事的，别担心你的工作，别担心那些东西。没事的，挺好。
So to see how this song and dance goes over, I pick my spot way up high in the stands and sit with some delegates. I find Todd Gilman, this delegate from Michigan I know, and make him watch Sean O'Brien's speech with me. Todd's retired, a Navy vet. He was in a union decades ago. He got involved with the Republican Party just a few years ago. And he's organizing a county commissioner race now. We're chatting.
所以为了看看这场表演效果如何，我在看台高处找了个位置，和一些代表坐在一起。我找到了我认识的密歇根州代表托德·吉尔曼（Todd Gilman），让他跟我一起看肖恩·奥布莱恩的演讲。托德已经退休了，是名海军退伍军人。他几十年前加入过工会，几年前才开始参与共和党事务。他现在正在组织一场县专员竞选。我们正在聊天。
How's that going, those races or those campaigns?
那些竞选进行得怎么样了？
I think they're going good.
我觉得进行得很顺利。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Todd has never heard of Sean O'Brien and does not care about him, it seems. All he knows about Teamsters is, where did the mafia bury Jimmy Hoffa's body? We're waiting for O'Brien's spot in the lineup when, suddenly, an unannounced guest appears.
托德似乎从没听说过肖恩·奥布莱恩，也不关心他。他所知道的关于卡车司机工会的一切就是：黑手党把吉米·霍法的尸体埋在哪里了？我们正等着奥布莱恩上台，突然，一位未宣布的嘉宾出现了。
Oh, Trump's here.
哦，特朗普来了。
He's in the building.
他在楼里。
Trump himself, not scheduled to speak, shows up on screen with a dramatically bandaged ear. It's the first night of the convention, our first time seeing him, and his first time in public since the assassination attempt. The crowd is losing it, the cameras following him down the hall toward the convention room like he's a fighter headed into the ring.
特朗普本人，原本没有安排发言，出现在屏幕上，耳朵上贴着巨大的绷带。这是大会的第一晚，我们第一次见到他，也是他自暗杀未遂后首次公开露面。人群沸腾了，摄像机跟着他穿过大厅走向会场，就像他是一名走向拳击台的斗士。
Oh, look at his ear.
哦，看他的耳朵。
He might be coming out. Your Teamster guy might not be talking.
他可能会出来。你的卡车司机那哥们可能没机会讲话了。
The crowd is jonesing for Trump, but Trump does not take the stage. He sits in the audience. And instead, the guy who appears on stage is--
人群渴望着特朗普，但特朗普并没有走上舞台。他坐在观众席中。取而代之的是，出现在舞台上的人是——
Lee Greenwood?
李·格林伍德（Lee Greenwood）？
Country singer.
乡村歌手。
He's going to play "Proud to Be an American." And then--
他要唱《以身为美国人为荣》（Proud to Be an American）。然后——
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
哦，是的，是的，是的。
"Proud to Be an American" is Trump's theme song this campaign. It's generally a signal he's about to take the stage. Only this time, the singer himself is here live, giving a sort of impromptu prayer benediction as images of Trump waving and grimacing appear on screen, turning the white-swaddled ear from side to side.
《以身为美国人为荣》是特朗普这次竞选的主题曲。通常这标志着他即将上台。只不过这次，歌手本人就在现场，给了一种即兴的祈祷式祝福，屏幕上不断出现特朗普挥手和做鬼脸的画面，让那只缠着白绷带的耳朵转来转去。
As Donald Trump turned his head just slightly that the bullet missed him just enough to save his life to be the next president of the United States.
当唐纳德·特朗普稍微转动头部，子弹就差那么一点没击中他，救了他的命，让他成为下一任美国总统。
The crowd sings "Proud to Be an American" with enthusiasm, then chants for Trump.
人群热情地唱着《以身为美国人为荣》，然后高呼特朗普的名字。
[CHANTING "WE WANT TRUMP"]
（高呼“我们要特朗普”）
But Trump still does not take the stage. Instead, this random guy limps out and stands there, one of the many regular Americans on the program who feel hurt by Biden's policies. He's dubbed onscreen as a grandfather. You've got to feel for him. The crowd is chanting, we want Trump, right into his face. Then another rando with the same story of not being able to afford stuff. Then Amber Rose-- how to describe-- model and influencer talks about seeing the light and voting Republican.
但特朗普仍然没有上台。取而代之的是，这个随机出现的家伙一瘸一拐地走出来站在那儿，他是节目中许多对拜登政策感到不满的普通美国人之一。他在屏幕上被称为“一位祖父”。你不得不为他感到同情。人群直接对着他的脸高呼“我们要特朗普”。然后是另一个有着同样无法负担生活开支故事的普通人。然后是安珀·罗丝（Amber Rose）——怎么描述呢——模特和网红，讲述自己看到真相并投票给共和党。
Oh, she does have a forehead tattoo.
哦，她确实有个额头纹身。
Overall, the vibes are way off. Trump's still in the room. People are clamoring for him to speak. And then finally, the last speaker of the night, instead of Trump, it's the president of the Teamsters Union, the outsider guy, the person who doesn't necessarily belong here.
总的来说，气氛非常不对劲。特朗普还在房间里，人们强烈要求他讲话。最后，当晚最后一位发言者不是特朗普，而是卡车司机工会主席，那个局外人，那个本来不一定属于这里的人。
Is this the mob boss?
这就是黑帮老大吗？
There he is.
他在那儿。
This is the mob boss?
这就是黑帮老大？
All right, now, you pay attention. Tell me what you think.
好了，现在，注意听。告诉我你怎么看。
He's probably a mob boss if he's a Teamsters president.
如果他是卡车司机工会主席，他可能就是个黑帮老大。
Clearly, O'Brien has some assumptions about union bosses to overcome with this crowd.
很明显，奥布莱恩在这个人群中需要克服一些关于工会大佬的假设。
Greetings, delegates and guests. I'm Sean O'Brien, general president of the International Brotherhood of Teamsters.
各位代表和来宾，大家好。我是国际卡车司机兄弟会总主席肖恩·奥布莱恩。
OK, big applause. And it just gets bigger.
OK，掌声雷动。而且掌声越来越大。
And I think we all can agree, whether people like him or they don't like him, in light of what happened to him on Saturday, he has proven to be one tough SOB.
我想我们都能同意，无论人们喜欢他还是不喜欢他，鉴于周六发生的事情，他已经证明了他是一个坚强的硬汉。
Biggest applause line of the night by far, like the catharsis of waiting for Trump is satisfied by this, a line that Sean will tell me he came up with right then, wasn't on the teleprompter. He was just feeling it. My Michigan delegate, Todd, is cheering, along with his military buddy, Bob, from Wisconsin. Bob leans over.
这是当晚最响亮的掌声，就像等待特朗普的宣泄通过这一点得到了满足。肖恩后来告诉我，这一句是他临时想到的，提词器上没有。他只是有感而发。我的密歇根代表托德正和他的威斯康星州战友鲍勃一起欢呼。鲍勃凑过来。
This is huge. I mean, you've got all these different people that voted for Joe Biden-- and their families did-- coming out here and speaking. This could turn out to be a total butt-kicking in November.
这太厉害了。我是说，你让这些曾经投票给乔·拜登的人——以及他们的家人——都站出来发言。这可能会导致十一月份的一场彻底惨败。
Now, the Teamsters are not endorsing Trump tonight. Sean O'Brien has been quite clear about that. But Bob from Wisconsin is just hearing the Teamsters throw their weight behind Trump. He's not paying close attention to the specifics of what Sean is saying, really. And as it goes on, the speech does get much more specific and much less Republican Convention-sounding, basically. He throws long-standing Republican allies, mainstays of the party, under the bus.
现在，卡车司机工会今晚并没有背书特朗普。肖恩·奥布莱恩对此表达得很清楚。但来自威斯康星州的鲍勃听到的只是卡车司机工会全力支持特朗普。他并没有真正关注肖恩所说内容的细节。随着演讲的深入，演讲内容变得越来越具体，也越来越不像共和党大会的风格。他实际上把共和党的老盟友、党的支柱都抛弃了。
But for a century, major employers have waged a war against labor by forming corporate unions of their own. We need to call the Chamber of Commerce and the business roundtables what they are. They are unions for big business. And here's another fact.
但一个世纪以来，大雇主们通过组建自己的企业工会，对劳工发动了一场战争。我们需要把商会和商业圆桌会议叫出原形。他们是大企业的工会。这里还有一个事实。
You think that's right?
你觉得对吗？
Yeah, he's right. I never thought of it that way, but he's 100% correct.
是的，他是对的。我从来没这么想过，但他百分之百正确。
He talks about major American companies, not as great examples of entrepreneurship, like at a typical Republican Convention, but as great examples of corporate greed.
他谈论大型美国公司时，不是像典型的共和党大会那样把它们作为创业的伟大典范，而是作为“企业贪婪”的伟大典范。
Companies like Amazon are bigger than most national economies. Amazon is valued over $2 trillion. What is sickening is that Amazon has abandoned any national allegiance. Amazon's sole focus is on lining its own pockets.
像亚马逊这样的公司比大多数国家经济体还要大。亚马逊的估值超过2万亿美元。令人作呕的是，亚马逊已经放弃了任何国家忠诚。亚马逊唯一的重点就是填满自己的腰包。
People are like, am I with this? Companies are bad? It's a little awkward. But then O'Brien pulls out a magic word that sells in this room.
人们心想：我支持这个吗？公司是坏的？这有点尴尬。但随后奥布莱恩抛出了一个在这个房间里很受欢迎的关键词。
Remember, elites have no party. Elites have no nation. Their loyalty is to the balance sheet and the stock price at the expense of the American worker.
记住，精英们没有政党。精英们没有国家。他们的忠诚在于资产负债表和股票价格，而牺牲的是美国工人。
I love this guy.
我喜欢这个家伙。
I can't stand Amazon.
我无法忍受亚马逊。
Yeah, I love this guy.
是的，我喜欢这个家伙。
Yep.
是的。
At some point, the crowd seems to hear themselves cheering wildly for organized labor and against corporatists. And it does get a little more strained-feeling in the room.
在某一刻，人群似乎听见自己在为有组织劳工疯狂欢呼，并反对企业集团。房间里的气氛变得有点紧张。
There are no consequences for the company, only the worker.
公司没有后果，只有工人有。
Right to work! Right to work! Someone is heckling the Teamster president kind of wonkily by screaming out the name of a policy that Teamsters hate. Right to work is a shot directly into the heart of unions' ability to organize. It's at the very center of Republican labor policy.
“工作权利”法（Right to work）！“工作权利”法！有人正通过高喊一个卡车司机工会痛恨的政策名称来刁难工会主席。“工作权利”法直接击中了工会组织能力的核心。这是共和党劳工政策的核心。
Right to work allows workers to work in a union shop without having to pay union dues. Advocates of the policy say workers should get to choose what they want. Unions hate it because they say workers then get the benefits of the contract without paying for it. It undercuts their power. There's over 150 Republicans co-sponsoring right-to-work bills in Congress right now. Trump has said he supports right to work.
“工作权利”法允许工人在工会企业中工作而无需支付工会会费。该政策的支持者说，工人应该能够选择他们想要的。工会讨厌它，因为他们说工人随后获得了合同的好处却不为此付费。这削弱了他们的力量。现在国会中有超过150名共和党人共同发起“工作权利”法案。特朗普也表示支持该法案。
Sean O'Brien continues to slam big business. And I'm almost expecting him to talk about Bernie's millionaires and billionaires. The applause in the room is getting weaker.
肖恩·奥布莱恩继续抨击大企业。我几乎以为他要谈论桑德斯的“百万富翁和亿万富翁”了。房间里的掌声变得微弱了。
These companies offer no real health insurance, no retirement benefits, no pay leave, relying on underfunded public assistance. And who foots the bill? The individual taxpayer. The biggest recipients of welfare in this country are corporations. And this is real corruption. We must put workers first.
这些公司不提供真正的医疗保险，没有退休福利，没有带薪假，依赖于资金不足的公共援助。谁来买单？个人纳税人。这个国家最大的福利接受者是企业。这是真正的腐败。我们必须把工人放在首位。
By the end of the speech, Todd's feeling about this guy he'd never heard of before--
演讲快结束时，托德对这个他之前从未听说过的家伙的感受是——
He's knocking it out of the park. I'm glad I stuck around and listened to him. Thanks.
他讲得太棒了。我很高兴我留下来听了他的演讲。谢谢。
When I talked to O'Brien after the speech, in the lobby of the grand Pfister Hotel, I wanted to know if he felt what I was feeling, about the awkwardness in the room, the uncertain silence, when he started wailing on the Chamber of Commerce and big American companies.
当我在大菲斯特酒店大堂采访演讲后的奥布莱恩时，我想知道他是否感受到了我所感受到的那种尴尬，那种当他开始痛斥商会和美国大公司时，房间里的那种不确定性的沉默。
Did you feel a feeling in the room like this is going over weird?
你有没有感觉到房间里有种奇怪的感觉？
Not at all. Not at all. I mean, I felt real comfortable. I knew that-- it's like anything else. If you're in a crowd and someone's talking about a situation and you may think you are the subject of it or you may think that pertains to you, it may be a little bit more uncomfortable for them than it was for me.
完全没有。完全没有。我的意思是，我感觉很自在。我的意思是，这就像其他事情一样。如果你在人群中，有人正在谈论某种情况，而你认为自己可能是对象，或者你认为这与你有关，那么对他们来说可能比对我来说更不舒服。
Overall, he feels pretty great about the speech. He got his message out. He thinks that now, he'll get calls from Republican legislators who weren't meeting with him before. Like, there's this one Senate bill right now that the big unions are really fighting for. It's called the PRO Act, Protecting the Right to Organize Act.
总的来说，他对自己演讲感觉很好。他传达了他的信息。他认为现在，他会接到之前不愿见他的共和党议员的电话。比如，现在有一项参议院法案，大工会正在为此努力奋斗。它叫《PRO法案》，即《保护组织权利法案》。
It's all Democrats. There's not a single Republican signer onto that bill.
那全是民主党人的事。没有一个共和党人签署该法案。
Not yet. Not yet, but we're working on it.
还没签，还没签，但我们正在努力。
Do you think you got some people--
你觉得你拉到人了吗——
Well, the bill that's currently there.
嗯，目前的法案在那里。
Right.
是的。
Right. So if you know you're not going to get support-- it's not going to pass-- wouldn't it make sense to figure out what could pass bipartisan?
是的。所以如果你知道你得不到支持——它不会通过——那么找出什么是两党都能通过的不是更有意义吗？
Yeah. So do you think you got people in that room to reconsider?
是的。所以你认为你让那个房间里的人重新考虑了吗？
I know that for a fact.
我确定这一点。
How do you know?
你怎么知道？
Because I've had the conversations.
因为我进行了谈话。
Can you give me an example?
你能给我一个例子吗？
I cannot, but stay tuned.
我不能，但请继续关注。
Now, the very next day, the Teamsters announced there was a new co-sponsor of the House version of the bill, a third Republican House member from Oregon. Because of the speech? We don't know.
第二天，卡车司机工会宣布该法案的众议院版本有了新的共同发起人，那是来自俄勒冈州的第三位共和党众议员。是因为这次演讲吗？我们不知道。
Rick Smith, the 35-year Teamster with the radio show, watched the convention, watched the speech from his union president, and I called him afterwards.
里克·史密斯，那位拥有广播节目的35年工龄卡车司机，观看了大会，观看了工会主席的演讲。我事后给他打了电话。
I fear he did everything that I thought he was going to do, because, look, I don't think anybody remembers what he says tomorrow other than, Trump's a tough SOB. There may be a quote, but what they're going to remember is he was there for Donald Trump.
我担心他做了我所想的一切，因为看，除了“特朗普是个坚强的硬汉”，没人会记得他说了什么。可能会有一句引语，但他们会记得的是他当时站在唐纳德·特朗普那边。
Rick saw Sean's speech as just another piece of the political theater playing out at the RNC, more working man cosplay, like Trump's selection of JD Vance as vice president, in his opinion. Sean O'Brien praised Vance in his speech. Vance's brand is kind of made-in-America economic populism. He famously walked a UAW picket line in Toledo.
里克认为肖恩的演讲只是在共和党全代会上上演的政治表演的另一部分，更多的“蓝领工人装扮”，就像特朗普选择万斯作为副总统一样。肖恩·奥布莱恩在演讲中赞扬了万斯。万斯的品牌某种程度上是“美国制造的经济民粹主义”。他曾因在托莱多参加UAW罢工而闻名。
I go back to this idea that there are Republicans that support labor. JD Vance walked a picket line. Yeah, OK, he walked the picket line. But he doesn't support workers' right to organize. And I know he'll give on something here or there. But ultimately, this is a guy who's not a friend of labor.
我回到这个想法，即有支持劳工的共和党人。万斯参加了罢工。是的，好吧，他参加了罢工。但他不支持工人的组织权利。我知道他会在某处让步。但最终，这家伙不是劳工的朋友。
And it seems simple to me. These are the people who are going to put the final nail in the coffin of the labor movement. And I think he gave them the kind of fodder that they can use. It's like handing an ax murderer an ax and then being surprised. What does Trump always say about a snake biting you because a snake is a snake, right?
对我来说，这很简单。这些人将成为劳工运动棺材上的最后一颗钉子。我认为他给了他们可以利用的筹码。这就像把斧头交给杀人犯，然后表现得很惊讶。特朗普总是说什么关于蛇咬你，因为蛇就是蛇，对吧？
Yeah, it's the snake's nature.
是的，这是蛇的本性。
Right, and this is-- that's these people's nature.
对，这就是这些人的本性。
O'Brien's response is, maybe the snake is changing. We can make them change. Parties change. You can't get things done if that's your uncompromising approach.
奥布莱恩的回应是，也许蛇正在改变。我们可以让他们改变。政党会改变。如果那是你不妥协的方法，你就什么都做不成。
I mean, look, you look at the Democratic Party 20 years ago as compared to now, I think we can all agree there's been significant change. Conversely, you look at the Republican Party 20 years ago and look at it today, I mean, there's been significant change.
我的意思是，看看民主党20年前与现在的对比，我想我们都能同意发生了重大的变化。相反，看看共和党20年前和今天，我的意思是，发生了重大的变化。
But you don't have to go back 20 years in this case, with this election. You can look at the Biden administration and the Trump administration. And one is more pro-labor than the other.
但在这次选举中，你不需要回到20年前。你可以看看拜登政府和特朗普政府。一个比另一个更支持劳工。
There's no doubt about that. And I can speak to that all day long. I mean, President Biden fixed pensions, brought a lot of work, passed the CHIPS Act, infrastructure bill, all that stuff. There's no doubt. But that doesn't mean that we can't work with anybody else that doesn't have the same labor record. And maybe they can-- obviously, if they have the opportunity, they can do good things for working people as well.
毫无疑问。我可以整天谈论这个。我的意思是，拜登总统修复了养老金，带来了大量工作，通过了《芯片法案》、基础设施法案等等。毫无疑问。但这并不意味着我们不能与任何其他没有同样劳工记录的人合作。也许他们可以——显然，如果有机会，他们也可以为劳动人民做些好事。
This sounds either wickedly pragmatic or hopelessly naive. But however much the Democrats and Joe Biden have done for organized labor, the Democrats could definitely lose in November. And Trump, who was sitting right across the hall from O'Brien up on stage performing, watching him closely with that martyred ear, he might be the guy he'll have to negotiate with.
这听起来要么是极度务实的，要么是无可救药的天真。但无论民主党和乔·拜登为有组织劳工做了多少，民主党确实可能在十一月失败。而那个当时坐在奥布莱恩对面舞台上表演、用那种受难的耳朵紧盯着他的特朗普，可能就是他不得不谈判的对象。
Zoe Chace is a producer on our show.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人。
Act two, Out on a Limb. You know who July hasn't been so great for? The Democratic politicians who were out front before anybody, publicly calling for President Biden to drop out of the election.
第二幕，孤注一掷。你知道七月对谁来说不太好过吗？那些在任何人之前就公开呼吁拜登总统退选的民主党政客。
Out of 260 Democrats who sit in the House and Senate, only 21 stepped forward, 20 from the House of Representatives and one senator, for the first three weeks after the presidential debate. No Democratic governors. No former presidents. But this small group called for Biden to drop out, hoping an army was going to form behind them. Then a week passed, then another week, and the battalions did not show up. They hung out there by themselves.
在参众两院的260名民主党人中，只有21人挺身而出，20名众议员和1名参议员，那是总统辩论后的最初三周。没有民主党州长，没有前总统。但这一小群人呼吁拜登退选，希望军队能在这场运动后面形成。然后一周过去了，又一周，营队没有出现。他们孤零零地站在那里。
Finally, at the end of this week, we heard about big names in the party, Pelosi, Schumer, Jeffries, behind the scenes, urging the president to step aside. With that cover, going into the weekend, the number of elected lawmakers started edging up very slowly. And finally, of course, Joe Biden bowed out of the race. But it took over three weeks for things to get to this point.
终于，在本周结束时，我们听到了党内大佬佩洛西、舒默、杰弗里斯在幕后敦促总统退选。有了这个保障，进入周末，当选议员的人数开始缓慢上升。当然，乔·拜登最终退出了竞选。但事情走到这一步花了超过三周的时间。
So what was it like for the people who stuck their necks out and waited? Well, Congressman Seth Moulton agreed to talk to me about all that. He's a Democrat from Massachusetts, a rising star in the party, had a brief presidential run himself in 2020, a former Marine who served four tours in Iraq. In fact, he led a platoon in the first company to enter Baghdad.
那么对于那些挺身而出并等待的人来说，那是什么样的经历呢？国会议员塞斯·莫尔顿（Seth Moulton）同意与我谈谈这一切。他是来自马萨诸塞州的民主党人，党内的一颗冉冉升起的新星，2020年曾短暂竞选总统，一名前海军陆战队员，在伊拉克服役了四个任期。事实上，他率领了第一家进入巴格达的连队中的一个排。
Years ago, he did a memorable interview on our program about this interpreter who he worked with and got close to in Iraq who ended up coming to the States and living in Moulton's childhood home with his parents. Basically, he became part of their family while waiting to get asylum because of all the death threats against him for collaborating with Americans.
多年前，他在我们的节目中做过一次难忘的采访，关于他在伊拉克共事并结下深厚友谊的一名翻译。那个人最终来到了美国，住进了莫尔顿父母的家里。基本上，他成为了他们家庭的一部分，同时因为与美国人合作而面临的所有死亡威胁，一直在等待庇护。
Joe Biden took an interest in Seth Moulton back when Moulton first ran for Congress in 2014, when Biden was vice president. Biden went to Massachusetts to do a rally endorsing him. And they rode in a car together, where Moulton says the vice president offered him half of his peanut butter and jelly sandwich. And he was not sure if you're supposed to say no to that offer from the vice president. So he said yes.
乔·拜登在2014年莫尔顿首次竞选国会议员时就对他产生了兴趣，当时拜登还是副总统。拜登去马萨诸塞州参加集会支持他。他们坐在同一辆车里，莫尔顿说副总统给了他一半的花生酱果酱三明治。他不确定是否应该拒绝副总统的提议，所以他接受了。
Moulton's age and his military experience, Moulton says Biden's told him a few times he reminds him of his son, Beau. Moulton and I spoke this past Monday, July 15. He told me the story of turning his back on Joe Biden starts, of course, on debate night.
莫尔顿的年龄和他的军事经历，莫尔顿说拜登曾几次告诉他，他让他想起了自己的儿子博（Beau）。我和莫尔顿在上周一，7月15日进行了交谈。他告诉我，背弃乔·拜登的故事确实是从辩论之夜开始的。
Well, I think, like most Americans, I felt the debate was an unmitigated disaster for President Biden. I mean, we all remember the times he couldn't keep his train of thought. He lost his place. He seemed incoherent. I thought one of the most remarkable moments was when he literally took our best issue, abortion, and pivoted immediately to our worst issue, immigration. I mean, you almost couldn't make it up.
嗯，我想像大多数美国人一样，我觉得那场辩论对拜登总统来说是一场彻底的灾难。我的意思是，我们都记得他无法保持思路连贯的时刻。他忘记了自己说到哪儿了。他看起来语无伦次。我认为最引人注目的时刻之一是他直接拿走了我们最好的议题——堕胎，并立即转向我们最糟糕的议题——移民。我的意思是，你简直编都编不出来。
I want to ask you a question that I worry might be a little awkward for you to answer. And I hope you can answer it honestly. The side of President Biden that we all saw on television that night during the debate-- you're in DC. You hear a lot of things, I'm sure. Had you seen that side of him before that night? Had you heard about that side of him before that night? Is that something people talk about?
我想问你一个问题，我担心你回答起来可能有点尴尬。我希望你能诚实地回答。那天晚上辩论期间我们在电视上看到的拜登总统的那一面——你在华盛顿，我相信你听到了很多事情。在那天晚上之前你见过他那样子吗？在那天晚上之前你听说过他那样子吗？这是人们谈论的事情吗？
Yes. Yes, it is. I've seen the president fairly regularly as a member of Congress, although it does feel like his staff is hiding him far more than they used to. But I've seen a dramatic change, in particular over the last several months. I saw him at the White House Christmas Ball. And he looked older and frailer. But he was excited to see me, quickly recounted things we've done together or whatnot.
是的。是的，确实。作为国会议员，我相当经常见到总统，尽管感觉他的工作人员比以前更隐瞒他了。但我确实看到了一个巨大的变化，特别是在过去几个月里。我在白宫圣诞舞会上见到他。他看起来更老更虚弱。但他很高兴见到我，很快地复述了我们一起做过的事情之类的。
Then I saw him, most recently, just a few weeks ago in Normandy, for the 80th anniversary of D-Day. He was speaking with a small group of us. And the change was pretty dramatic.
然后我最近，就在几周前在诺曼底，为了诺曼底登陆80周年纪念日见到了他。他和我们的一小群人说话。这种变化非常巨大。
How so?
怎么说？
Well, it was more like the things that we saw in the debate. Not that bad, but more in that direction.
嗯，更像是我们在辩论中看到的那些。没有那么糟，但更朝那个方向发展。
Like him having a hard time summoning the words for things?
比如他很难用词来表达事物？
Yeah, more like that, yes. But as someone who's been a very long-time Joe Biden fan, as someone who's admired him, as someone who's been a mentee of his, it was hard to see. And it was concerning, to the point where, although I don't think there's a single American who expected what we saw the night of that debate, I wasn't entirely surprised.
是的，更像那样，是的。但作为一个长期以来的乔·拜登粉丝，作为一个钦佩他的人，作为一个他的门生，这很难看。而且这令人担忧，以至于虽然我认为没有一个美国人预料到我们在辩论那晚看到的情况，但我并不完全感到惊讶。
So when we came back to the House floor the next day, everyone was sharing the same view. I didn't speak to anyone who thought it was OK other than Speaker Pelosi, who just said, well, I don't know that we can judge a campaign by one debate. But I really felt she had to say that.
所以第二天当我们回到国会大厅时，大家的看法是一样的。我没跟任何觉得这没问题的人谈过，除了佩洛西议长，她只是说，好吧，我不知道我们能否通过一场辩论来判断一场竞选。但我真的觉得她必须这么说。
Party leaders are in a little bit different position. But all of us in the rank and file thought it was a total disaster. And I think most of us were clear that the only way forward for Democrats to have a chance in this election is to get a new nominee at the top of the ticket.
党内领导人的处境有点不同。但我们这些普通议员都认为这是一场彻底的灾难。而且我认为我们大多数人都清楚，民主党在这场选举中有机会的前进道路，就是获得一个新的提名人。
Over the next few days, Moulton says, he tried to call everybody he knew in the White House, anybody close to the inner circle, to express his concerns about the president's performance and the path ahead.
在接下来的几天里，莫尔顿说，他试图给他在白宫认识的每一个人、任何接近核心圈子的人打电话，以表达他对总统表现和未来道路的担忧。
I made a lot of phone calls. And I got nothing in response. Now, I'm not offended by that. I don't want to come across as thinking that the White House should return my phone calls. But given the circumstances, you'd expect some low-level aide to just give me a call and say, we've heard your concerns. Here's what we're doing about them. But it was just a wall of silence.
我打了很多电话。但我没有得到任何回应。现在，我并不因此感到冒犯。我不想让别人觉得我以为白宫应该回我的电话。但鉴于这种情况，你会期望某个低级助手给我打个电话说，我们听到了你的担忧。这就是我们正在做的。但那只是一堵沉默之墙。
What did that say to you?
那说明了什么？
It said to me that they're not taking this seriously. We needed to hear a new plan. And first, you just simply need to hear that they're being honest about the situation at hand. But I wasn't hearing any of that.
这说明他们没有认真对待这件事。我们需要听到新的计划。首先，你需要听到的是他们对目前的情况表现得诚实。但我根本没听到这些。
When I came home to Massachusetts, I held a Zoom meeting with a lot of local Democratic officials. And these are people who tend to be very establishment players. They want to stick with the status quo, by and large. So I expected the majority of them to be in favor of Biden remaining on the ticket. I'd say it was about 80% in favor of his stepping aside. That was powerful as well.
当我回到马萨诸塞州时，我和许多当地民主党官员举行了Zoom会议。这些人倾向于非常建制派。他们想要坚持现状。所以我预计他们中的大多数人会支持拜登留任。我得说大约80%支持他退选。那也很强大。
It's five days after the debate before the first Democratic lawmaker calls for Biden to step down. A day later, a second one does. That same night, Moulton releases a very polite, pretty hedgey statement saying, "I have grave concerns about President Biden's ability to defeat Donald Trump," and then going on to say if the president can't demonstrate that he can do a better job prosecuting the case against Trump, quote, "We should have all viable options on the table." So that goes out.
辩论五天后，第一位民主党议员呼吁拜登退选。一天后，第二位也这么做了。就在当晚，莫尔顿发表了一份非常有礼貌、相当回避的声明，说：“我对拜登总统击败唐纳德·特朗普的能力深表关切，”然后继续说，如果总统不能证明他能更好地起诉针对特朗普的案件，引语，“我们应该把所有可行的选择都摆在桌面上。”所以这发出去了。
But then later that night, I showed my statement to a friend who was visiting, a Marine. And this great friend of mine, who I trust for advice, he read it, and he said, what are you trying to say? I said, well, I'm basically saying that he should step aside.
但后来当晚，我给一位正在探访我的朋友看我的声明，那是一名海军陆战队员。我信任他的建议，他读了之后问，你到底想说什么？我说，好吧，我基本上是说他应该退选。
And he said, well, then why don't you just say it, Seth? And I gave him this long explanation for why being polite was the appropriate thing to do here and actually more likely to result in mission accomplishment. Let's be respectful of the president and push him gently in the right position, not be so explicit.
他说，那为什么不直接说出来呢，塞斯？我给了他一个长篇大论，解释为什么有礼貌是这里的适当做法，实际上更有可能实现任务成就。让我们尊重总统，轻轻地把他推向正确的位置，而不是那么直接。
But I thought about it a lot that night. And I woke up thinking about it the next morning. And I decided, if I honestly think he should step aside, then you know what? I should just say it. And so the next morning on the one interview I did, a local NPR station--
但我那天晚上想了很多。第二天早上醒来时我还在想。我决定，如果我真心认为他应该退选，那么你知道吗？我应该直接说出来。所以第二天早上我接受的唯一采访，在当地一家NPR电台——
WBUR.
WBUR。
When we were talking about the statement, I just simply added those few words. He should step aside.
当我们谈论那个声明时，我只是简单地加了那几个字：他应该退选。
And with that, Seth Moulton became the third Democrat to demand the president step down. He told me he didn't expect tons of his colleagues to join him and follow suit, even though so many of them agreed that Biden should step aside. That's just how Congress works, he says. He's in other situations where his colleagues agree on important stuff behind the scenes but don't take a public stand.
就这样，塞斯·莫尔顿成为第三位要求总统退选的民主党人。他告诉我，他没指望他的同事们会成群结队地加入他，效仿他，尽管他们中许多人都同意拜登应该退选。他说，这就是国会的工作方式。他处在其他情况下，他的同事们在幕后对重要的事情意见一致，但不会公开立场。
I didn't, frankly, expect a lot of people to jump right in with me. But I mean, I'm sorry to admit that.
坦率地说，我没指望很多人会立刻加入我。但我的意思是，我很抱歉承认这一点。
And so what happened? Watching the news, I really wondered if, for somebody like you, if after making a statement like that-- you're walking through the halls of Congress. You're going down to the floor. Are you, like, a pariah? Are people not meeting your eye? What's it like?
那么发生了什么？看着新闻，我真的很想知道，对于像你这样的人，在发表了那样的声明之后——你走在国会大厅里。你走到会场。你像是个贱民吗？人们避开你的目光吗？那是种什么样的经历？
Well, it was interesting. I was very curious what would happen the first time I came back to Washington and walked out onto the House floor for votes that evening. And it did seem like people were just avoiding me, like they didn't want to be caught in a conversation. But it was totally different as soon as I walked into the cloakroom, in other words, away from the reporters and the TV cameras. And people had a lot of nice things to say.
嗯，这很有趣。我很好奇第一次回到华盛顿走上国会大厅投票时会发生什么。看起来人们确实在避开我，好像他们不想陷入对话。但一旦我走进衣帽间，换句话说，远离了记者和电视摄像机，情况就完全不同了。人们有很多好话要说。
He says he did try to lobby some of his colleagues, told him they should come forward publicly also. And a few did. But generally, most did not. And why not? Fear, best as he can tell. They were scared of ticking off the president and his team, of going against the Democratic establishment, of sticking their necks out.
他说他确实试图游说他的一些同事，告诉他们也应该公开站出来。有几个人做了。但总的来说，大多数人没有。为什么不呢？他能确定的只有恐惧。他们害怕惹恼总统和他的团队，害怕违背民主党建制派，害怕挺身而出。
That fear is not entirely unreasonable. Michigan Congresswoman Hillary Scholten was kicked out of a Democratic Party planning meeting to coordinate get-out-the-vote efforts because, Politico reported, the Michigan State Democratic Party didn't like the fact that she called on President Biden to step down.
这种恐惧并非完全不合理。密歇根州女众议员希拉里·肖尔滕（Hillary Scholten）被踢出了一个民主党规划会议，该会议旨在协调投票工作，因为Politico报道称，密歇根州民主党不喜欢她呼吁拜登总统退选。
Moulton told me the main time he heard anybody make any kind of principled argument against speaking out was at a meeting of the Democratic caucus. This is Democratic members of the House. They met 12 days after the debate to discuss Biden.
莫尔顿告诉我，他听到有人反对公开站出来发表原则性论点的主要时间是在民主党核心小组会议上。这是民主党众议院议员。他们在辩论后12天开会讨论拜登。
People who were concerned about the chaos or supposed chaos of what might come next, the people who were unsure whether this should go directly to Vice President Harris or should be some sort of open mini-primary, as James Carville and Jim Clyburn have suggested.
那些担心混乱或所谓接下来可能出现的混乱的人，那些不确定是否应该直接传给哈里斯副总统，还是应该进行某种詹姆斯·卡维尔（James Carville）和吉姆·克莱伯恩（Jim Clyburn）建议的某种开放式迷你初选的人。
Moulton spoke at that meeting. And afterwards, he says, colleagues who were not sticking their necks out publicly continued to tell him that they liked what he was saying and doing in public.
莫尔顿在会议上发言。事后他说，没有公开站出来的同事继续告诉他，他们喜欢他在公开场合所说和所做的一切。
Do you feel impatient or frustrated with them?
你对他们感到不耐烦或沮丧吗？
Yes. Yes. I mean, I'll be honest. Look, I know people have very different political backgrounds and constituencies to represent. I know some people are hearing more folks back home who just want Biden to stay in the race. At least, I'm guessing that they do.
是的。是的。我的意思是，我会诚实地说。听着，我知道人们有着非常不同的政治背景和需要代表的选区。我知道有些人在家乡听到了更多只是想让拜登留在竞选中的人的声音。至少，我猜他们是这样。
And what is your read of the politics of this? Like, you're in a safe Democratic district or a pretty safe Democratic district. Is this good for you politically? Like, calls and emails and texts and stuff to your office, are they mostly people supporting you, coming out and saying this about the president?
你对这个政治局势有什么看法？就像，你在一个安全的民主党选区或一个相当安全的民主党选区。这对你政治上有利吗？就像，给你们办公室的电话、邮件和短信之类的，大多是支持你的人，站出来支持你对总统的这种说法吗？
Interestingly, the calls and messages we've received from people in the district are very supportive. It's just, thank you for saying what we all saw. But there seems to be some kind of organized campaign nationally to attack me, because a lot of the messages on social media, on Twitter, and to our office that come from outside the district have been highly critical.
有趣的是，我们从选区收到的电话和信息非常支持。只是，谢谢你说了我们大家所看到的一切。但全国范围内似乎有一种有组织的运动来攻击我，因为社交媒体上、Twitter上发给我们的信息，以及从选区外发来的信息都非常尖刻。
Wait, wait. Do you think it's possible that your own party or your own president is organizing people to yell at you online?
等等，等等。你认为你的政党或你自己的总统有可能在组织人们在线上骂你吗？
I mean, that's pretty standard practice, I think. I don't know if that's exactly what's happening right now, or it's just self-organizing groups, or even Twitter bots. I mean, I don't really know. We haven't spent a lot of time digging into it.
我的意思是，我认为这是相当标准的操作。我不知道现在到底发生了什么，或者只是自发组织的团体，甚至是Twitter机器人。我的意思是，我真的不知道。我们没有花太多时间去深究它。
For a lot of us reading news reports during the three weeks before President Biden dropped out, as the days rolled on and President Biden kept insisting that he didn't think he lost any ground in the race and he wasn't going to listen to anybody but himself on this, the chances of him actually leaving the race seemed to get more and more remote.
对于我们许多在拜登总统退选前三周关注新闻报道的人来说，随着日子的推移，拜登总统一直坚持认为他没有失去选情，他不会听从除他自己以外的任何人的意见，他确实离开竞选的可能性似乎变得越来越遥远。
But this past Monday, Congressman Moulton told me that from where he sat, the whole thing was still very much an open question, even after the assassination attempt on Donald Trump and that photo with his fist in the air.
但上周一，莫尔顿议员告诉我，从他的角度来看，即使在唐纳德·特朗普遇刺未遂以及那张挥拳照片出来后，整件事仍然是一个悬而未决的问题。
I mean, look, from my narrow perspective, and the phone calls I've received, it's intensified calls for President Biden to step aside. It's going to be even harder for Democrats to win after that attempted assassination. And so how do we increase pressure on the White House?
我的意思是，看，从我狭隘的角度，以及我收到的电话来看，这加强了要求拜登总统退选的呼声。在暗杀企图之后，民主党获胜变得更加困难。那么我们如何增加对白宫的压力？
I understand that you were on a phone call that President Biden was on this weekend. What can you say about that?
我理解你这个周末参加了一个拜登总统也在其中的电话会议。你能说说关于那个电话会议的情况吗？
It was a Zoom meeting. And he was speaking with the new Democratic coalition. And well, there were a few dozen of us on with him. And I'm not going to share details of a confidential meeting. But I'll just say that it was discouraging. It left me feeling affirmed of my position and felt like things are bad and getting worse. I mean, this was not a high-stakes debate. This was just a low-stakes conversation with a bunch of fellow Democrats. But it didn't go terribly well for the president.
那是一个Zoom会议。他正在与新的民主党联盟通话。嗯，有几十个人和他一起在线。我不会分享机密会议的细节。但我只想说那是令人沮丧的。它让我感到自己的立场被证实了，感觉情况很糟并且正在恶化。我的意思是，这不是一场高风险的辩论。这只是一次低风险的对话，和一群民主党同僚在一起。但对总统来说谈得并不好。
How so?
怎么说？
It just seemed like he's not taking our concerns seriously, making a lot of excuses, on the one hand, citing polls that say he's doing better while dismissing all the bad polls by saying polls don't matter, and just continuing to refuse to answer this question about, how are you going to turn things around, sir?
看起来他没有认真对待我们的担忧，找了很多借口。一方面引用民调说他做得更好，同时通过说民调不重要来驳回所有糟糕的民调，并继续拒绝回答这个问题：先生，你打算如何扭转局面？
So as we record this, it's Monday, July 15. 19 members of Congress and one senator are with you, basically, in total, calling for President Biden to step down. And then the rest of the Democratic Party elected officials are on the other side. How is that feeling?
所以当我们录制这段节目时，是7月15日周一。基本上有19名国会议员和1名参议员和你在一起，要求拜登总统退选。然后其余的民主党当选官员都在另一边。那种感觉如何？
Well, first of all, that's just not an accurate characterization. 19 plus 1 are public. The majority are with me. And so therefore, how does it feel? It feels frustrating.
嗯，首先，那不是一个准确的定性。19加1是公开的。大多数人是站在我这边的。所以因此，感觉如何？感觉很沮丧。
Can I ask you, are you in a sort of a perverse situation, where, when you watch the president now on TV, you're sort of hoping for him to slip up? Like, if he slips up more, it'll speed--
我可以问你吗，你是否处在一种反常的境地，当你在电视上看总统时，你是在希望他滑倒？就像，如果他滑倒更多，它会加速——
No. No, no no.
不。不，不，不。
--him on the path towards having to step down?
——他不得不退选的道路？
It's an interesting question. No, I'm not hoping the president will slip up. But I am hoping that something happens to push him over the edge, just to make him realize, to face reality here.
这是个有趣的问题。不，我不是希望总统滑倒。但我确实希望发生些什么能把他推向边缘，只是让他意识到，去面对现实。
I think it's important to say, Ira, that I genuinely love Joe Biden. He's been a great mentor to me. He's consistently given me great advice. I have nothing but good things to say about Joe Biden.
我认为很重要的一点是，艾拉，我真诚地爱乔·拜登。他一直是我伟大的导师。他一贯给我很好的建议。关于乔·拜登，我只有好话要说。
Is there some moment between you that especially stands out or you think captures what it's like being-- or what it was like in the past between you and him?
在你们之间有什么时刻特别突出，或者你认为捕捉到了作为——或者过去你和他之间是什么样的？
President Biden used to have me over for breakfast when he was vice president. We'd sit at his residence. And of course, breakfast was always scheduled for about an hour and it would go for close to three. And he would regale me with stories from his time in the Senate and the lessons that he's learned about politics over the years.
拜登总统当副总统时常请我吃早餐。我们会坐在他的官邸里。当然，早餐通常安排大约一个小时，但会持续近三个小时。他会跟我讲述他参议院任职期间的故事，以及他多年来从政治中学到的教训。
I'd ask very serious questions, pose situations where I needed advice. And he genuinely took me under his wing. It felt like he was invested in me personally. Now, there are hundreds of people in politics who know Joe Biden better than I. I'm still relatively new to this whole thing. But I like him a lot. I could tell that he cared.
我会问非常严肃的问题，提出我需要建议的情况。他真诚地把我带在身边。感觉他个人对我有投入。现在，政界有数百人比我更了解乔·拜登。我对这一切还比较陌生。但我很喜欢他。我看得出他在乎。
Knowing him to the degree that you do, are you surprised that he won't give up?
了解他到你这种程度，你惊讶他不会放弃吗？
He's incredibly tenacious. But I also know he's dedicated to our country. And there's a well-worn phrase in the Marines that they try to drill into you day after day in training, which is, it's not about you.
他极其顽强。但我同时也知道他致力于我们的国家。在海军陆战队中有一句老话，他们试图在训练中一天又一天地灌输给你，那就是：这不是关于你自己的。
And that's my fundamental message to President Biden today, is, sir, this is not about you. You're an amazing president. You've been an incredible senator. You've done so much for the United States of America. And now, the best thing you can do is to step aside and give us just a little bit better chance at defeating Donald Trump and winning this election.
这就是我今天给拜登总统的基本信息，先生，这不是关于你自己的。你是一位了不起的总统。你曾是一位不可思议的参议员。你为美利坚合众国做了这么多。现在，你能做的最好的事情就是退选，给我们一点点更好的机会去击败唐纳德·特朗普，去赢得这场选举。
Congressman Seth Moulton from Massachusetts. Again, we spoke on Monday, well before the president decided to step down.
来自马萨诸塞州的塞斯·莫尔顿议员。同样，我们在周一进行了交谈，远在总统决定退选之前。
Coming up, typing with your pinkies, how it has the power to make you rethink everything about your own sister. We have a true-life example. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，用小指打字，它如何有力量让你重新思考关于你妹妹的一切。我们有一个真实生活的例子。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续之后的一分钟内。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Big Rethink, stories of people reconsidering something fundamental about themselves and the way they see themselves and what happens next. We've arrived at Act Three of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《大重思》，讲述人们重新考虑关于自己以及他们看待自己的方式的一些根本性东西，以及接下来发生了什么的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。
Act three, Anything You Can Do, I Can Do Backwards. OK, so in this time of country-defining decisions, we close our show out today with yet another story of critical import about two sisters and their pinkies, a story Elna Baker stumbled on.
第三幕，你做到的任何事，我都倒着做。好的，在这个国家决定性的时刻，我们今天用另一个关于两个姐妹和她们的小指的故事结束我们的节目，这是一个具有重要意义的故事，艾尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）偶然发现的。
I was chatting with a friend of a friend, Zoe Kushlefsky, at a bar when she casually mentioned she was about to attempt to break the world record for speed typing the alphabet using only her pinkies. It took me a minute to process. There's a world record for typing with your pinkies? How do you even know that's a thing? Where does that idea even come from? And that's when Zoe said--
我在酒吧和朋友的朋友佐伊·库什列夫斯基（Zoe Kushlefsky）聊天时，她随口提到她正要尝试打破世界纪录，用小指打字最快完成字母表。我花了一分钟来处理这个信息。用小指打字还有世界纪录？你怎么知道这是一回事？那个想法是从哪儿来的？那就是佐伊说——
My sister. I stole it.
我妹妹。我偷来的。
Sisters-- so twisted, right? My sister has something, and I want to take it from her. Here's how it all started. One day, Zoe's sister, Eliza, texted her this. "LOL, I don't know if you heard, but I broke a world record tonight, fastest time typing the alphabet backwards with my pinky fingers. LOL, I did it in 6.31 seconds. And the record is 9.65.
姐妹——太纠结了，对吧？我妹妹有一样东西，我想把它从她那夺走。这是这一切的开始。一天，佐伊的妹妹伊莱扎（Eliza）给发了条短信：“哈哈，不知道你听说了没，我今晚打破了一个世界纪录，用小指倒着打字母表的最快时间。哈哈，我用了6.31秒。纪录是9.65。”
My next texts were, "LOL, what? That's so bizarre and cool. Bet I can do it in 6:30. I'm going to ruin your night."
我接下来的短信是：“哈哈，什么？那太离奇也太酷了。打赌我能在6.30秒内完成。我要毁了你的夜晚。”
Wow. So it was sort of instantaneous, your desire to take this record from her?
哇。所以你想从她那儿夺走纪录的愿望是瞬间产生的？
Yeah, I guess so. And I was joking, but it was coming from a true place of, I really do bet I could do it. Like, should I? No, I shouldn't. Unless--
是的，我想是的。我当时在开玩笑，但这源于一个真实的想法，我真的敢打赌我能做到。比如，我该做吗？不，我不该做。除非——
So Zoe opens her laptop and gives it a try, starts typing the alphabet backwards with her pinkies. She's not great, but she's improving rapidly and live-texting Eliza as she gets better.
于是佐伊打开笔记本电脑试了试，开始用小指倒着打字母表。她不太擅长，但她在迅速提高，并在变得更好时实时给伊莱扎发短信。
And she said, "If you keep practicing, I bet you can get it." And I said, "I think I could, too, but I would feel like an asshole, LOL." She said, "They have the same one for alphabet forwards. The record is 5.7 seconds." And I said, "With pinkies? That would be kind of sick if I got forwards and you got backwards, LOL." Got to throw the LOL in there to soften it, as always.
她说：“如果你一直练习，我打赌你能做到的。”我说：“我也觉得我能，但我会觉得自己像个混蛋，哈哈。”她说：“他们正向打字母表也有一样的纪录。纪录是5.7秒。”我说：“用小指？如果我能做到正向而你做到倒向，那会很酷的，哈哈。”总是得加个“哈哈”来软化语气。
Zoe, right then and there, decided that she would go for trying to beat the record for typing the alphabet with your pinkies forward, like she's not dethroning her sister and taking her record.
佐伊就在那一刻，决定去尝试打破用小指正向打字母表的纪录，就像她不是在废黜她妹妹并夺走她的纪录一样。
Because to me, that was a way to just ever so slightly sidestep the idea of coming for her gig.
因为对我来说，那是一种稍微侧面回避想要抢她风头的想法的方式。
And did you think that was going to work? Did you think that was believable?
你以为这会管用吗？你以为这可信吗？
No.
不。
There's a specific kind of mind game endemic to sisterhood. And I want to use this stupid pinky thing to examine that, how something so small can blow up because of deep stuff from the past. Like in Zoe's case, from her perspective, Eliza has always been upstaging her. They're both just a few years out of college, but Eliza is already a software engineer with a high-paying job. Zoe's a nanny. Eliza travels the world. Zoe binge watches Vanderpump Rules.
姐妹关系中存在一种特定类型的心理游戏。我想用这件愚蠢的小指琐事来检查这一点，一件如此微小的事情如何因为过去深层的东西而爆发。比如在佐伊的情况下，从她的角度看，伊莱扎一直在抢她的风头。她们都大学毕业几年了，但伊莱扎已经是拥有高薪工作的软件工程师。佐伊是个保姆。伊莱扎环游世界。佐伊在疯狂观看《Vanderpump Rules》。
And Eliza's always racking up some new achievement. Like, she only came up with the idea to break the world record because she needed something to do after running her first half marathon, whereas Zoe feels left behind in life. She moved to LA to become a TV writer but hasn't had the confidence to try yet.
而伊莱扎总是在积累新的成就。比如，她打破世界纪录的想法只是因为她在跑完第一个半程马拉松后需要找点事做，而佐伊觉得在生活中被落在了后面。她搬到洛杉矶想成为电视编剧，但一直没信心去尝试。
And this leads me to the second thing you need to know. The day Zoe got the text from Eliza, it was a big day for Zoe. Just that afternoon, she had finished four months of treatment in a super intense eating disorder program.
这就引出了你需要知道的第二件事。佐伊收到伊莱扎短信的那天，对佐伊来说是个大日子。那天下午，她刚刚完成了在一个超级紧张的饮食失调项目中四个月的治疗。
Like, I'm talking eating all my meals in the company of a therapist, basically, or a nutritionist. And now, I was like, OK, now it's time to work myself back into the real world.
我的意思是，我在治疗师或营养师的陪伴下吃掉所有的饭菜，基本上。现在，我想，好吧，现在是时候把自己放回真实的世界了。
Does it feel like she's rubbing her life in your face?
感觉她在把她的生活往你脸上抹吗？
Yes. I mean, for a few good minutes, I was-- I was just kind of like, this was my-- like, I felt really proud of myself for getting through treatment. I felt like I had just kind of had my own accomplishment.
是的。我的意思是，有几分钟，我只是觉得——我对完成治疗感到非常自豪。我觉得自己刚完成了一个属于我自己的成就。
And that's when-- record scratch-- she got the text from Eliza, and photos. Eliza was surrounded by friends. Everyone's raising their pinkies and celebrating.
就在那时——唱片刮擦声——她收到了伊莱扎的短信和照片。伊莱扎被朋友们簇拥着。每个人都在翘着小指庆祝。
And I'm sitting alone on my couch. No one is around me. I'm just sitting, kind of stewing in my own emotions. So I was a little bit-- yeah, I was a little bitter. I was like, doesn't she know it's my last day of treatment? Like, doesn't she know how horrible the timing of this is? I just was bitter. I was just like, congratulate me. This isn't-- this is my moment. This was supposed to be my thing.
而我独自坐在沙发上。我身边没人。我只是坐在那儿，沉浸在自己的情绪中。所以我有点——是的，我有点苦涩。我想，难道她不知道这是我治疗的最后一天吗？我的意思是，难道她不知道这个时机有多糟糕吗？我只是苦涩。我只是想，祝贺我。这不是——这是我的时刻。这本该是我的事。
So Zoe finds a typing speed website that can time her and starts rage-typing with her pinkies. To give you an idea of how absurd this looks, hold up your pinkies like Dr. Evil and try to type anything. Now try to do it faster. Now faster. Now repeat that for months. Insane, right? But Zoe became completely fixated on winning.
于是佐伊找到了一个可以计时打字速度的网站，开始用小指愤怒地打字。为了让你知道这看起来有多荒谬，像邪恶博士那样翘起你的小指，试着打字任何东西。现在试着打得更快。再快。现在重复几个月。疯了，对吧？但佐伊变得完全执着于获胜。
Zoe and Eliza are stepsisters. When Zoe was eight, her dad met Eliza's mom. And within a couple years, he lived with Eliza's mom and Eliza. Zoe would visit every other weekend. Zoe was already self-conscious about her weight. Her dad was always on her about it. And right away, she started comparing her body to Eliza's.
佐伊和伊莱扎是继姐妹。佐伊八岁时，她爸爸遇见了伊莱扎的妈妈。几年之内，他住进了伊莱扎妈妈和伊莱扎的家。佐伊每隔一个周末来访。佐伊一直对自己的体重很自觉。她爸爸总是唠叨她。很快，她就开始把自己的身体和伊莱扎进行比较。
Eliza, it always just seems to come naturally to. She was always athletic. She ran track. I felt like Eliza was the daughter that my dad dreamed of.
伊莱扎，这似乎总是自然而然。她一直很有运动细胞。她跑田径。我觉得伊莱扎是我爸爸梦想中的女儿。
For dessert, he might serve Zoe fruit, while Eliza got pie. There'd be little critical comments. Zoe's dad had been fat, lost weight his senior year of high school, and felt like it made life so much easier. He thought he was helping Zoe, but now sees how wrong-headed all that was.
吃甜点时，他可能会给佐伊水果，而伊莱扎吃馅饼。会有一些小小的批评意见。佐伊的爸爸曾经很胖，高中最后一年减了肥，觉得这让生活容易多了。他以为他在帮佐伊，但现在看到了这种做法是多么错误。
But as a teenager, Zoe decided that since Eliza was thin and got good grades and everything seemed easy for her, that Eliza was the favorite, and she was more of a burden. All these past wounds ready to rip open with one ill-timed text.
但作为青少年，佐伊决定，既然伊莱扎很瘦，成绩又好，一切对她来说似乎都很容易，那么伊莱扎就是最受宠的，而她更像是个负担。所有这些过去的伤口都准备好被一条不合时宜的短信撕开。
All this from a pinky world record. It is all connected, but it is pretty wild that all this stuff is coming up.
这一切源于一个小指世界纪录。它们都有关联，但这一切涌现出来确实有点狂野。
Six months go by, and Zoe's getting faster by the millisecond. Early on, she double-checks with Eliza. Are you sure you're OK with this? And Eliza's like, yeah, sure. So Zoe trains on. Finally, she's ready to go for it.
六个月过去了，佐伊打字速度每毫秒都在提高。早些时候，她和伊莱扎再三确认。你确定没问题吗？伊莱扎说，是啊，当然。于是佐伊继续训练。终于，她准备好去挑战了。
To officially break the record, Zoe has to video her attempt to break the record and send it into Guinness. And so on the day of her first attempt, she invited friends over.
为了正式打破纪录，佐伊必须录下她尝试打破纪录的视频，并将其发给吉尼斯。所以在她第一次尝试的那天，她邀请了朋友过来。
I wore sweatbands around my head and my wrists because it was, like, my athletic, Olympian event.
我头上和手腕上都戴着汗带，因为这就像我的运动奥林匹克赛事。
Like, your Rocky moment.
就像你的《洛奇》时刻？
Yeah, it was fully my Rocky moment. And I should have gotten tiny little sweatbands for my pinkies. That was a missed opportunity. I did my little slate, where I say, my name is Zoe Kushlefsky.
是的，完全是我的《洛奇》时刻。我本该给我的小指准备小小的汗带。那是个错失的机会。我做了我的小板子，上面写着，我的名字是佐伊·库什列夫斯基。
Hi, my name is Zoe Kushlefsky.
嗨，我的名字是佐伊·库什列夫斯基。
I'm here in Los Angeles.
我在这里，在洛杉矶。
I'm in Los Angeles, California. I am attempting to break the record for the fastest time to type the alphabet with the little fingers. Oh, and I'm here with my witnesses, Rebekah Kochan--
我在加利福尼亚州的洛杉矶。我正在尝试打破用小指打字母表的最快时间。哦，我和我的证人丽贝卡·科汉（Rebekah Kochan）在这里——
Woo!
呜！
--and Ben Ligouri.
——和本·利古里（Ben Ligouri）。
Yay.
耶。
Zoe goes up to her computer, holds her hands in the air, cracks her knuckles, and wiggles her fingers, warms up her pinkies.
佐伊走到电脑前，把手举在空中，扳了扳指关节，扭动手指，热身她的小指。
OK.
好的。
I'm in position.
我准备好了。
Great. OK. Are we ready? OK. 3, 2, 1, go. Done.
太棒了。好的。准备好了吗？好的。3，2，1，开始。完成了。
You got it?
你拿到了吗？
I got it.
我拿到了。
4.6 seconds. The record to beat was 5.12. After a few months, Guinness writes her back. She was now the Guinness World Records' time holder. Zoe calls up Eliza to tell her the good news. She let me sit in and record.
4.6秒。纪录是5.12。几个月后，吉尼斯回信了。她现在是吉尼斯世界纪录的时间保持者。佐伊打电话给伊莱扎告诉她这个好消息。她让我加入并录音。
So, yeah, I got the record. How do you feel about that?
所以，是的，我拿到了纪录。你对此感觉如何？
I'm excited for you.
我为你感到兴奋。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah.
是啊。
Eliza congratulates her, but also says--
伊莱扎祝贺她，但也说——
For me, I'm really over the whole record thing, to be honest. For me, it was-- like, it's almost been-- what-- like, nine months now since I did it? And so I'm very over it. I'm just excited for you. I don't really care anymore, from my perspective. I did what I set out to do.
对我来说，老实说，我真的对那个纪录的事情感到腻了。对我来说，它——就像——离我做那件事已经过了九个月了？所以我很腻了。我只是为你感到兴奋。我真的不在乎了，从我的角度看。我完成了我打算做的事情。
So for me, it was just, yeah, something fun to do. And so it doesn't really matter to me anymore, all the specifics. I don't know. It just depends what it meant to you. I think it could have been-- it was different for you. But for me, I mean, it wore off a while ago. So it passed pretty quickly for me. But for you, it might be different.
所以对我来说，这只是，是的，做些有趣的事情。所以我不再关心所有细节了。我不知道。这只取决于它对你意味着什么。我认为它可能是——对你来说是不同的。但对我来说，我的意思是，它早就不存在了。所以对我来说过得很快。但对你来说，可能会有所不同。
True, true.
真的，真的。
I felt like I could hear Zoe deflating on the call. She went from cheering and laughing to being ashamed for even caring. This was such a sister counterattack. She seemed so harsh. But when I sat down with Eliza to talk about it, she was warm, self-deprecating.
我觉得我能听到佐伊在电话那头泄气。她从欢呼和欢笑变成了因为自己在意而感到羞耻。这简直是姐妹间的反击。她看起来如此严厉。但当我坐下来和伊莱扎谈论它时，她是热情的、自嘲的。
I come in frazzled. My hands have a little ketchup on them.
我走进来时心烦意乱。我的手上有一点番茄酱。
So I played the call for her and just asked her, what was up with that?
所以我给她放了录音，只是问她，怎么回事？
How do you think you sound in this?
你觉得你在这录音里听起来怎么样？
Not great. I mean, I think I sound defensive and upset.
不怎么好。我的意思是，我觉得我听起来很防御且难过。
Defensive?
防御？
I think so. I'm like, I don't even really care. But for you, it's different. Oh, this matters to you, but it doesn't matter to me. For you, it's good.
我想是的。我说，我根本不在乎。但对你来说，这不同。哦，这对你很重要，但对我来说不重要。对你来说，这很好。
Here's the thing. Eliza knew Zoe was recording her. And in good sister fashion, she'd said she was OK with it, but she wasn't really. So she was flustered and uncomfortable. And she had other feelings, too. This itch Zoe has to take her down, Eliza's noticed, and it doesn't feel great. If you look at the story from her perspective, Eliza breaks a world record. And when she first texts her sister, hey, I did this cool thing. Zoe's response is, fuck your thing.
事情是这样的。伊莱扎知道佐伊在录音。按照姐妹的方式，她说没关系，但她其实并不这么想。所以她惊慌失措且不舒服。她也有其他感受。佐伊想打倒她的那种痒，伊莱扎注意到了，而且感觉不太好。如果你从她的角度看这个故事，伊莱扎打破了世界纪录。当她第一次发短信给妹妹，嘿，我做了这件很酷的事。佐伊的回应是，去你的事。
And I guess I was just like, why is her first response to compete with me and one-up me? And I was just like, instead of being happy for me, she saw it as this competition. And her first response was, I can do it better. This is this cool thing that I tried to achieve. And now you're trying to beat it.
我想我当时的想法是，为什么她第一次回应是跟我竞争并试图超过我？我只是觉得，她没为我高兴，却把它看作是一种竞争。她的第一次回应是，我能做得更好。这是我努力实现的很酷的事。现在你却试图打败它。
Yeah, why are you coming after me?
是的，你为什么要来找我麻烦？
Yeah. And I think it's the fact that her first text after was, I bet I can do it faster.
是的。我想这就是事实，因为之后的第一条短信是，我打赌我能打得更快。
Right, she didn't even say congratulations first.
对，她甚至没先说恭喜。
Yeah. So then it's like, if that's where this is coming from, that feels hurtful. The entire way it was phrased was just doing it better than me.
是啊。所以这就感觉很伤人。整个表达方式只是为了比我做得更好。
Eliza didn't say any of this to Zoe, though. She felt like it was a dumb thing to get her feelings hurt over. So instead, she texted Zoe, I dare you. Eliza says, Zoe always trying to one-up her this way-- Eliza doesn't get it.
伊莱扎并没有对佐伊说这些。她觉得因为这点事受伤很傻。所以她发短信给佐伊，我敢打赌你做不到。伊莱扎说，佐伊总是试图通过这种方式超过她——伊莱扎不明白。
You personally have never felt like you've been competing with Zoe?
你个人从来没觉得你在跟佐伊竞争吗？
Not competing. To me, it's not even comparable. I've always admired the fact that she's out in LA, living her dreams. And it's just that she is in a very different career path. But I always think everything she is doing there is amazing. And she's married. And she has a house.
不是竞争。对我来说，这甚至没有可比性。我一直钦佩她身在洛杉矶，过着她的梦想。只是她是在一个非常不同的职业道路上。但我一直觉得她在那里做的每一件事都很棒。而且她结婚了。她有一栋房子。
Yes, Zoe is married. She lives in a nice house. She and her wife have a great relationship. Eliza hasn't yet checked off those big life boxes. She's also, Eliza told me, the performer of the family, the one who upstages her. Plus, Zoe's the oldest. She's actually the big sister. Eliza's like, you win.
是的，佐伊结婚了。她住在一栋漂亮的房子里。她和她妻子关系很好。伊莱扎还没有勾选那些大的人生选项。她也是，伊莱扎告诉我，家里那个表演者，那个抢她风头的人。加上，佐伊是最大的。她实际上是大姐姐。伊莱扎说，你赢了。
I felt like she set the tone. Like, she was player one on the Wii. She had to go to the bathroom first when we got home from the car ride. Like, not in any resentful way, just in like a, that was the pecking order. You're the oldest sibling. Like, that felt right. And I think she even said to me, too. I think she said she feels like there's a point where it flipped. And to her, I felt more like the older sister.
我觉得她定下了基调。就像，她是Wii上的第一玩家。当我们在车里回到家时，她得先去洗手间。不是那种怨恨的方式，只是那种，那才是等级顺序。你是最大的兄弟姐妹。我觉得那是对的。而且我想她甚至也对我说了。我想她说她觉得有一个点翻转了。对她来说，我觉得更像大姐姐。
But that never happened for me. I've always seen her as the older sister. I still look up to her a lot. I think I still really like to get her approval. I don't know if she said. But actually, someone made a comment about that recently in our family, that I like to get her approval. So to me, I've always looked up to her and admired her, and I still do.
但那对我来说从未发生。我一直视她为大姐姐。我仍然非常仰望她。我想我仍然真的很想得到她的认可。我不知道她是否说过。但实际上，最近家里有人对此发表了评论，说我喜欢得到她的认可。所以对我来说，我一直仰望她并钦佩她，而且我仍然这么做。
She told me she had no idea that the day she texted Zoe about her world record was the day Zoe ended treatment. And Zoe never said anything. And she also had no idea that from the time they were kids, Zoe felt inferior to her.
她告诉我，她完全不知道她发短信给佐伊关于世界纪录那天是佐伊结束治疗的那天。佐伊从未说什么。她也完全不知道从她们小时候起，佐伊就觉得不如她。
Yeah, that's shocking to me.
是的，那对我来说太震惊了。
Shocking?
震惊？
Yeah. I mean, I just don't see myself in that role. Like, wow. Like, she's doing so much better. I didn't realize she felt like that.
是啊。我的意思是，我并不把自己看作那个角色。哇。我的意思是，她做得好多了。我没意识到她会有那种感觉。
Eliza says that growing up, she had no idea Zoe thought Eliza was the favorite, the daughter their dad really wanted. She never noticed that she got dessert and Zoe got fruit.
伊莱扎说，成长过程中，她完全不知道佐伊认为伊莱扎是最受宠的，是他们爸爸真正想要的女儿。她从没注意到她得到了甜点，而佐伊得到了水果。
I mean, it makes me sad to think that. Some of that, I think, especially now that we're older, I'm very aware of. But I definitely, again, wasn't as a child. And it makes me sad to think of Zoe going through all that and feeling very alone and me having no idea. Like, that is so isolating.
我的意思是，想到那让我感到难过。我想这其中一些，特别是在我们长大后，我是非常清楚的。但我肯定，再次重申，作为孩子时我并不知道。想到佐伊经历这一切并感到非常孤独，而我一无所知，这让我感到难过。我的意思是，那太孤立了。
But then I also see it from your perspective, because it sort of has nothing to do with you.
但然后我也从你的角度看它，因为它与你没有关系。
But it does-- like, I don't see it from my perspective. It does have to do with me, I mean, even if it doesn't directly. Like, I wish I could have been there for her and-- yeah, I don't know why I wasn't. Like, I don't know, just being younger and just not seeing these things. And maybe it's not something that I was primed to think about. So I wasn't even noticing.
但它确实有关系——我的意思是，我不是从我的角度看它。它与我有关系，我的意思是，即使不是直接相关。我的意思是，我希望我当时能陪在她身边——是的，我不知道为什么我没做到。我的意思是，只是因为更年轻而且没有看到这些事情。也许这不是我天生会去想的事情。所以我当时根本没注意到。
Since this whole pinky record thing, for the first time, Zoe and Eliza have started talking about all this, directly. They called each other, compared notes. Zoe was like, oops, I didn't say congratulations after you got your record, did I? And Eliza was like, I had no idea you thought my job was cool.
自从整个小指纪录这件事以来，佐伊和伊莱扎第一次开始直接谈论这一切。她们打电话给对方，比较笔记。佐伊说，哎呀，我没在妳拿到纪录后说恭喜，对吧？伊莱扎说，我根本不知道妳觉得我的工作很酷。
And Zoe, who in one sentence will say she admires Eliza and in the next say she's jealous, has realized that they're two sides of the same coin, and how she feels about Eliza in any given moment has everything to do with how she feels about herself. And she's being more generous with her. It all looks different now, to both of them.
而佐伊，在一句话中说她钦佩伊莱扎，在下一句中说她嫉妒，意识到她们是同一枚硬币的两面，以及她对伊莱扎的任何感觉都与她对自己的感觉有关。她对她变得更加慷慨了。现在这一切对她们两人来说看起来都不一样了。
Elna Baker, she's the cohost of the podcast Pretty Sure I Can Fly with Johnny Knoxville. Listen wherever you get your podcasts. Her story was produced by Lilly Sullivan and edited by Nadia Reiman.
艾尔娜·贝克，她是播客《Pretty Sure I Can Fly with Johnny Knoxville》的联合主持人。在妳获取播客的任何地方收听。她的故事由莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）制作，娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）编辑。
Well, our program was produced today by Susan Burton and Dana Chivvis and edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put our show together today include Chris Benderev, Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Hany Hawasly, Henry Larson, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ryan Rumery, Alix Spiegel, Ike Sriskandarajah, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
好的，我们的节目今天由苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）和达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）制作，劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）编辑。今天参与我们节目制作的人员包括克里斯·本德雷夫、詹达伊·邦兹、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、哈尼·哈瓦斯利、亨利·拉尔森、托宾·洛、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、瑞恩·鲁默里、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和戴安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Barry. Special thanks today to everybody at WUWM, especially David Lee and Ele Ellis. Also thanks to Ben Terris, Mike Elk with PayDay Report, Mike Pesca, Sarah McCammon, Don Gonyea, Jonathan Weisman, and Paula Moura.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。如果你在今年暑假长途开车或者在等飞机时想听些什么，你可以完全免费地从我们超过800集的档案中流式播放。免费，你听到了吗？thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流电台（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. If you're looking for something to listen to during a long drive during this holiday summer or while you're waiting for planes to fly, you can stream from our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Free, did you hear me? thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。当他在华盛顿特区时，他实际上会去参加乔·拜登参加的同一堂瑜伽课。但老师太专横了。托里不得不不断地告诉她——
Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. When he's in Washington, DC, he actually goes to the same yoga class that Joe Biden does. But the teacher is so overbearing. Torey keeps having to tell her--
让我们尊重总统，轻轻地把他推向正确的位置。
Let's be respectful of the president and push him gently in the right position.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，欢迎收听《美国生活》的更多故事。